salut vous vous demandez sûrement
pourquoi ce titre disséquer la dame a et
des lettres 1,6 euro etc
et bien simplement parce que 10 c'est
qu'elle adams est l'anagramme de le
marquis de sade
alors pour bien comprendre faut
connaître le marquis de sade c'était un
homme politique romancier et philosophe
qui adorent et mélanger le sexe avec la
barbarie donc la violence le meurtre
l'inceste
ouais c'est de là que vient le mot
sadique est l'anagramme d'un mot ou
l'anagramme d'une phrase c'est le fait
de reprendre toutes les lettres d'une
phrase pour en former une nouvelle si on
prend toutes les lettres de le marquis
de sade
alors on obtient disséquer la dame
ondine anagramme c'est un nom féminin et
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner les
meilleurs anagramme que j'ai pu trouver
qui sont en plus en rapport avec la
phrase d'origine au mot d'origine comme
par exemple soigneurs qui est
l'anagramme de guérison c'est pas ce pas
un peu ouf
moi ça me rendrait le but du jeu c'est
que vous essayez vous aussi de trouver
si vous voulez les anagrammes vous
pouvez mettre pause vous pouvez chercher
et j'ai d'ailleurs invité des gens d'une
chaîne youtube que j'aime bien qui
s'appelle la famille lycos a essayé de
jouer avec moi de temps en temps dans
les vidéos maintenant vous allez voir
apparaître ce pouce alors se pousse il
veut dire quoi ce coup ci veut dire que
c'est un coup de pouce parfois quand je
vais présenter une chaîne un produit un
projet quelque chose que j'aime bien
mais qui n'est pas un placement produit
sur lequel je n'ai aucun intérêt
directement c'est juste actifs
je mettrai ce truc-là coup de pouce
pourquoi ben je vais vous le dire
pourquoi simplement parce que j'ai
remarqué qu'avec les placements de
produits un peu déguisés et c'est
maintenant vous les gens de l'autre côté
de l'écran vous savez jamais quand c'est
sincère ou pas et bien maintenant voilà
c'est clair quand il ya le logo coup de
pouce ça veut dire que c'est un truc que
j'ai kiffé et je veux le mettre en avant
ce qui est le cas pour la famille coste
on commence avec un anagramme très
simple océans aux séances a fait si on
mélange un petit peu
canoë ok canon eos et renvoie un peu le
rapport quand même merveille c'est
intéressant parce que merveille si on
mélange bien vous pouvez me pose si vous
voulez chercher ça fait mille rêves
j'aime bien c'est un petit peu de poésie
sur cette chaîne que diable la crise
économique
alors moi je trouve que c'est un rapport
après vous trouvez qu'il ya un rapport
ou pas mais c'est assez amusant de voir
ça c'est un article et deux mots qui
vont se transformer en un autre article
et deux mots et pour vous aider le
premier article c'est le et la technique
de dray est bonne parce que la barre et
les lettres qui était déjà utilisé
ensuite à la préparer les deux mots est
donc le premier mot fait bien huit
lettres
la tension n'a des deux mots vient
d'être trouvé alors je sais pas si vous
ne l'aviez vous mail à audresselles
viennent de trouver que comique était le
deuxième mot ce qui est bon et dans un
anagramme si tu trouves tous les maux
sauf un live vous êtes fortes chances de
trouver le deuxième scénario
oui scénario comique de scénarios comme
j'avais raison sur les quais web entrait
savent plus trop avoir un mac la clé
c'est que j'ai dit oui pour moi la crise
est inventé ok mais chirurgien or avons
trouvé un les mairies c'était pas le
plus dur en terme de nombre de lettres
par contre c'était le plus éloigné en
termes de rapport la crise économique ça
donne le scénario comique voire comique
pas pour tout le monde en l'occurrence
mais la crise économique
l'anagramme c'est le scénario comique et
bien que vous connaissez forcément qui a
été adapté d'ailleurs en français pour
fonctionner aussi mais il marchait déjà
en anglais cet homme elvis j'ai du sort
qui donne je suis voldemort et si t'as
pas lu harry potter forcément tu passes
un peu à côté
[Musique]
alors un grand classique c'est pas moi
qui l'ait trouvé celui ci mais je le
trouve assez fascinant c'est le
commandant cousteau pour ceux qui
connaîtraient pas le commandant cousteau
c'est quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup de
recherches et de reportages sur le
milieu marin à une époque tu as un peu
la star de l'océan dans les années 80-90
le mec y avait pas âme héros qui
connaissait pas le commandant cousteau
qui ont fait l'anagramme de le
commandant cousteau ça nous donne tout
commença dans l'eau je pense qu'on voit
dans les yeux le fait que ça me fascine
j'espère arriver à vous le rendre ça à
l'écran la gravitation universelle donc
vous connaissez la loi de la gravité la
gravitation universelle
quel est son anagramme si on mélange les
lettres il est assez dur à trouver parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de mots ça commence
par l'oie et s'adonne loi vital réunion
sur la ville le triangle des bermudes
bien avant les illuminati il y avait
donc le triangle des bermudes
et comme il ya beaucoup de bateaux qui
se sont perdus dans le triangle des
bermudes des avions qui ont eu des
problèmes avec les instruments de bord
rêve depuis tout temps les marins disait
qu'il se passait des choses très
étranges là-bas y avait une rumeur est
bien l'anagramme de le triangle des
bermudes c'est la rumeur des gens de la
mer
ça donne à réfléchir diana da g aussi
pour la phrase suivante l'origine de
l'univers ça donne un anagramme en
quatre mots l'origine de l'univers ça
donne un anagramme de quatre mots qui
donnent un vide noir grésy c'est un peu
c'est un peu jolie en fait c'est une
vidéo poétique que je vous fais
aujourd'hui
en parlant de poésie vous connaissez
aussi forcément cette phrase être ou ne
pas être
voilà la question bon c'est telle est la
question mais on va mettre voilà la
question parce que sinon on peut pas
fermer ma g que je veux derrière donc
être ou ne pas être
voilà la question et bien si on mélange
tout ça qu'on extrait toutes les lettres
qu'on les réutilise tout une fois pas
une fois de moins pas une fois de plus
ça nous donne oui et la réponse n'est
que vanité orale donc ça fait être ou ne
pas être voilà la question
oui et la réponse n'est que vanité orale
je trouve que ça colle bien dans le même
état d'esprit des choses qui colle bien
on a aussi les trous noirs sont irrésolu
dire que les trous noirs et sont ils
résolus les deux phrases sont une
anagramme l'une de l'autre les trous
noirs sont ils résolus
je crois que lesdits à cette fois un
autre que j'aime bien pour le côté
musical c'est robert schuman reconnu
brahms donc l'anagramme de robert
schuman ce s'est reconnue brahms et
c'est vrai que dans l'une de ses lettres
dans l'un de ses écrits
schumann fait des compliments comme
abrams est un grand artiste il a un
petit peu de données le tampon par
rapport à la musique que faisait brahms
donc robert schuman reconnu brahms c'est
un petit peu énorme anagramme s'il vous
plaît d'albert einstein
j'ai à présent des questions pour un
champion 1 à 10 en bas de votre écran
pamiers un bouton pour mettant un pouce
bleus si vous voulez ça ça fait plaisir
d'ailleurs l'année g de l'ès 1 pouces
bleus c'est si aucune poubelle parce que
tout ce que j'ai trouvé donc avec toutes
les lettres de l'ès 1 pouces bleus ça
fait si aucune poubelle
en clair s'il n'y a pas de poubelle dans
cette vidéo tu peux laisser un pouce
bleus bon je disais l'anagramme de
albert einstein
ça donne quoi si on récupère toutes ces
lettres de son prénom et son nom de
famille ça donne rien n'était établi
albert einstein rien est établi énorme
antoine de saint-exupéry donc c'est la
personne qui a écrit le petit prince
mais vous savez peut-être aussi qu'il
était aviateur et qu'il est vraiment
tombé en panne dans le désert un petit
peu comme dans l'est le petit prince est
bien l'anagramme d'antoine de
saint-exupéry seydoux cyril était en
panne de cire en référence au petit
prince et il était en panne pour faire
référence à la panne d'avion qu'il avait
lu dans le désert et les particules
élémentaires c'est une très bonne
question est ce que vous voulez chercher
peut-être un petit peu et les particules
élémentaires
bon je vais chercher ça
[Musique]
il est extrêmement compliqué ça fait
tisseyre l'espace et la lumière ce qui
ne peut nous donner une phrase complète
et les particules élémentaires tisseyre
laisse passer la lumière
c'est à 10 ans vous avez vu je vous fais
une référence plus historique ce
vercingétorix roi des gaules donc vous
souvenez vercingétorix a déposé ses
armes de francs césar en signe de
reddition
ça a été sa manière de rester fiers face
à l'ennemi et face à la défaite et bien
vercingétorix roi des gaules l'anagramme
de cet ensemble la donne digne vers toi
glorieux césar vercingétorix roi des
gaules digne vers toi glorieux césar il
ya vraiment un sens caché derrière ses
phrases
alors forcément c'est du hasard mais
c'est assez passionnant je vous mets au
défi de trouver un anagramme simple
alors spatule juste sur un mot ou sur
une phrase complète et de le mettre dans
les commentaires de la vidéo vous pouvez
aller voir sur internet mais c'est
encore mieux si vous en vous trouvez un
vous même et comme ça on va se faire
avec les commentaires toute une liste
non exhaustive des anagrammes possibles
et inimaginaux dans tous les domaines
possibles et inimaginaux je suis
vraiment ravi d'avoir pu vous présenter
en même temps la famille coste que moi
je suis depuis longtemps je suis abonné
à leur chaîne depuis un bon moment joué
évidemment un lien vers leurs chaînes
dans la description n'hésitez pas à les
check et ils se sont fait un petit défi
de ouf de faire le tour du monde en
famille on qui tente ou enfin je vous
laisse voir ça je vous invite bien sûr à
vous abonner à cette chaîne ça fait dupe
les digère c'est très bien si vous avez
qui fait la vidéo partagée l'a vraiment
partagé là c'est grâce à vous en fait
que la chaîne elle grandit aussi je
compte sur vos pouces par centaines de
milliers je ne sais pas pourquoi je
prendrais cet accent et c'est une vidéo
toutes les semaines je tire tous les
jours en fait deux fois par semaine les
mardis et vendredis à 15 heures et un
live le dernier mercredi de chaque mois
à 20h20 je vous dis à très bientôt et
ciao
si ça se trouve il ya un anagramme caché
en appuyant sur le cercle juste là au
milieu de l'écran c'est possible dans le
doute il faudrait essayer ça marche même
d'un téléphone portable
et si vraiment il n'y a pas d' anna g
savate abonnés et ce serait cool très
bon cool
[Musique]